[NARRATOR:] Hope is the ayahuasca of feelings,
And the Jets are flying high.
Before I was smiley to be polite.
Now I’m smiley because I’m happy!
He showed me the light.
I'm not a leader.
I'm a follower!
[helicopter noise]
[NARRATOR:] Some say he's washed.
[NARRATOR:] But to have him explain it,
It’s me. Hi, Savior. It’s me.
The New Yorkers in Gridiron
Heights have become eager followers.
So you had a drop.
That's okay. I'm chill now.
Um, I think the Giants are supposed
to be the main character.
-Quinnen. Sauce. Educate young Daniel.
-Ahh!
Hello, cameras. I no longer resent you.
I'm a different guy.
I attended the Taylor Swift
Eras Tour... twice.
He has so many weapons.
Do you read me?
Hello? Do you read me?
Yes. Josh, I'm f--ing right next to you.
[NARRATOR:] Others have tried to anoint
their own controversial saviors.
Now I realize if you have faith,
a sack is just a trust fall.
[THUD]
ANTHONY... RICHARDSON!
[crowd cheers]
Hello.
My name is Jordan Love, and
I used to be in the cult with Aaron Rodgers.
At first, it's interesting.
I wouldn't trust it. It's called Bluetooth
because it'll bite you.
But then he snaps...
...the football.
I was wondering if I could-?
WE'RE ONLY BEATING THE BEARS BY 30!
Now it's year four...
...and I have no idea if I'm good or not.
[NARRATOR:] Despite the many believers...
[cannon clicks]
[NARRATOR:] his enemies are quickly approaching.
[NARRATOR:] But first, the Lions take on Kansas City.
Gentlemen,
it is an HONOR to die with you all tonight.
Wait, what?
-Attack!
-Hut, hut, hut, hut.
[AIDAN HUTCHINSON:] OH GOD, HE THREW A NO-LOOK GRENADE.
[ALEX ANZALONE:] HE'S TEARING UP THE FIELD. GET COVER 1.
[MAHOMES:] TRAVIS! YOUR KNEE!
[KELCE:] MUST PLAY...FOR MY FANTASY MANAGERS.
[ST. BROWN:] AMON-RA WILL GET HIS REVENGE
[DAN CAMPBELL:] Hot damn, I love the fall.